une enseignante qui hurle et insulte des
élèves de première année
depuis hier c'est enregistrement du
groupe sanguin de l'école des grands
vents à Sainte-Marthe-sur-le-Lac
provoque la consternation il faut aller
au fond de l'histoire pour savoir ce que
quelqu'un qui savait à l'école
complètement inacceptable que des
enfants
reçoivent se fasse parc d'asser comme ça
c'est l'horreur au-delà de la violence
psychologique il y aurait aussi eu des
codes à but physique par cet enseignante
dans la classe depuis hier plusieurs
parents ont porté plainte la police de
deux montagnes a ouvert deux enquêtes
de l'intimidation c'est sûr et certain
que nous on va rencontrer la direction
le centre de service scolaire a suspendu
l'enseignante visée lundi donc le thé
suspendu sur le champ hier à deux heures
pourtant certains parents nous ont
confié avoir levé des drapeaux rouges à
la direction de il y a des heures
plusieurs mois que Madame elle est là
depuis quatre ans puis que oui
effectivement il y a eu des inquiétudes
de partager des plaintes verbales écrire
il y a eu des interventions ça c'est
important pour moi de le dire il y a des
interventions qui ont été faits par la
direction j'ai été très choqué pour ce
père dont la fille fait partie du groupe
101 la confiance envers la direction est
brisée il y a des gros changements
à faire dans cette école-là c'est sûr
que nous on est révolté car beaucoup de
questions demeure sans réponse pourquoi
les autres n'ont pas dénoncé
ça c'est un autre affaire ça c'est un
autre affaire qu'on comprend moins bien
parce que je veux dire toutes les
enfants des classes à côté l'ont entendu
mais pas les profs à l'Assemblée
nationale l'opposition juge que le
centre de service scolaire ne peut pas
mener cette enquête ce que j'ai de la
preuve qui démontre que le centre de
salut scolaire l'avocate ainsi que les
ressources humaines ça depuis
minimalement depuis janvier pour les
violences verbales et votre fait le
mandat d'enquête général que j'ai confié
à mes propres enquêteurs va également
aller enquêter au centre de services un
conseil d'établissement a lieu ce soir
ici à l'école des grands vents avec des
membres du personnel et des parents qui
comptent bien demander des comptes à la
direction et au centre de services
scolaires des Mille-Îles ici Jacques
auréchabonneau Radio-Canada à
Sainte-Marthe-sur-le-Lac